I want to continue talking about property rights today.
And I'm going to also,
uh,
address,
most of the lecture to the problem of taking [inaudible].
And when the government has the right to take private property for public
purposes and under what kinds of circumstances compensation is required,
uh,
and you were calling the fifth amendment of the constitution,
that private property can't be taken without compensation if it's going to be
used for public purposes.
Before we get there,
I want you to think about,
uh,
the,
the way that property rights are fractured by law,
but also by jurisdictional boundaries.
And I wanted to spend a moment,
uh,
to,
give you a sense of the kinds of problems that are experienced,
uh,
out in Wyoming in the Northwestern corner,
known as the greater Yellowstone ecosystem.
Uh,
and this is a,
an extraordinary area.
It's one of the last great tracks of,
of a forest lands in the,
uh,
in the northern Rockies.
And it also is a habitat to a variety of,
of,
uh,
large mammals,
many of which are either threatened or,
or rare or endangered.
And the jurisdictional boundaries are really complicated.
And I think very interesting.
There are several national parks,
uh,
the,
Yellowstone national park,
uh,
also,
the,
uh,
national forests,
the grand Teton national forest,
uh,
the,
several other,
a national wildlife refuges are,
are also in this area.
Uh,
several native native American reservations are,
are in this area as well.
And what you see on the right hand side of this slide is just one example of one
species of,
of wolves,
uh,
that,
cross these different boundaries.
So the purpose of this chart is to give you a sense that there are a wide number
of laws that are at play on the give a implementation authority to different
agencies such as the Forest Service,
the bureau of land management,
and the National Park Service,
uh,
the,
fish and Wildlife Service and also state complimentary state agencies.
And there are also a large,
uh,
set of private land owners that own,
a huge tracks of land so that it's a mixture of public and private,
uh,
rights that,
have a,
uh,
a complexity that,
often does not fare well for the natural resources in the area.
And the area is also rich in,
in natural gas as well as oil reserves,
uh,
that,
creates some other,
uh,
types of conflicts.
So a timber harvesting,
oil,
extraction of water rights,
uh,
all of these different resources,
need to be managed very carefully.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
the central problem represented by this map is that that a certain kinds of
resources such as wolves or grizzly bears or,
uh,
complexes of,
of species transcend these jurisdictional boundaries.
And,
and,
uh,
the forest service may have a very different policy than the national parks
service,
uh,
in determining how they're managed.
So the same species of a unusual timber,
uh,
might exist on forest service land and the Forest Service May,
be giving out leases to,
to extract those timbers timber,
uh,
resources.
Uh,
whereas the park service would not do so.
And I mentioned that in the problem of,
of a fire crossing these jurisdictional boundaries as well,
and having the forest service have a policy of fire suppression as opposed to
the park service's policy of,
of,
uh,
let it burn.
So that the fundamental problem here is that these resources are spanning the
jurisdictional boundaries.
And,
uh,
there,
there is inconsistency and the mission and intent of,
of these different agencies,
which I also think just a moment about the grizzly bears.
Grizzly bears are found in Yellowstone,
uh,
they're found in Canada and Alaska,
as well.
But consider that,
uh,
the,
the bear,
this bear,
uh,
was,
really a common property resource,
uh,
in legal terms.
It basically a w would cross from one area to another.
Uh,
this bear would be protected if it to happened to be wandering through national
park lands.
Uh,
but if it had wandered on,
uh,
on,
national park land,
say a up in Alaska,
uh,
that,
we're,
we're also on a native American lands that had been dead dedicated by the native
claims Settlement Act,
uh,
that applies to a Alaskan Lens.
Uh,
then this bear would be,
uh,
appropriable.
In other words,
uh,
native Americans that lived in that area would have the right to hunt this bear.
So,
I mean,
I think also about the idea of fish,
uh,
in addition to,
mammals such as this,
they are public resources until they're killed.
So if you get the right to,
uh,
to go hunting,
once you kill the animal,
uh,
then it becomes your private property.
Unless of course it's a rare threatened or endangered species,
but even they may be appropriable or shot,
uh,
or,
or caught,
uh,
under some,
provisions of,
of,
uh,
native populations rights.
So also think about the way that we allocate fishing rights.
Uh,
and in class,
uh,
I was asked,
in,
in section about the boundary that,
uh,
surrounds nations and a,
where the rights are to a,
to fish and,
and can,
can a different country come into the waters of the United States,
the jurisdictional boundary of the United States.
And,
and,
uh,
we have a 200 mile limit as to,
other nations,
uh,
within which,
we have the right to exclude other,
other,
uh,
parties or other groups from coming in and,
and,
uh,
fishing for a fishing,
for valuable a species.
I also want you to think about,
uh,
the main coast for a moment.
Uh,
this is an island.
I had an opportunity to,
uh,
become a steward or a manager of a nature conservancy preserve,
when I was a phd student here.
And,
and,
uh,
I actually had writing block.
I was having a hard time writing my doctoral dissertation and a,
I called a friend who I knew was managing some lands in for the Nature
Conservancy and asked if they had a reserve that,
uh,
they needed help with for a period of about six months in.
And uh,
I'll never forget her.
She was delighted to,
uh,
offer me a chance to sit on this island,
which is about 250 acres.
It has a population of zero.
Uh,
so I would be the only person there and that's the little,
uh,
that was my house for six months.
I had a picnic table that,
uh,
I looked out over the,
these these waters.
Uh,
this little shed was right about there.
The picnic table sat right there.
And uh,
so I cranked a,
the no electricity,
no running water,
uh,
just a little outhouse.
And uh,
the only person on the island and a,
I had a little Smith Corona,
a non electric typewriter.
So I cranked up 350 pages of my phd sitting there looking out to sea.
It was really quite an experience.
But I also learned a lot about property rights and how rights are allocated to,
uh,
to,
to fishermen on the Maine coast.
And you know,
lobster is a valuable resource.
And so how are fishermen allowed to,
uh,
to set traps?
You know,
what,
uh,
how is this regulated?
But it turns out that,
uh,
it's regulated differently by a different local governments and it's regulated
in a variety of ways.
Each,
each of these,
uh,
different buoys represented by a different colors you see here,
basically are allocated to individual.
So a color is assigned to a single individual.
They have a legal right to fish,
uh,
via a license that is provided by a local community.
And it's a license that a is not gained easily.
Uh,
in,
in most of these communities you are not allowed to get a license unless you've
lived there for a good part of your life or unless your,
your,
uh,
parents or grandparents have also,
fished in the area and they also regulate the number of traps that's allowed.
They're allowed to be put on the line.
So the deal is that a,
you have,
uh,
a buoy here.
It's tied by a rope a to one of these traps and that is linked by robe to
another trap.
And it may be a nine,
10 traps and in the times of,
of a lobster scarcity,
uh,
or during certain seasons of the year,
or they may restrict the number of traps.
So you stuff the bait inside the trap and then you throw it overboard when
you've got a,
uh,
you have a buoy on it on either end.
Well,
you know,
uh,
some Lobsterman,
our,
our fishing without licenses and,
uh,
it's kind of curious that the culture in Maine,
is extremely protective of property rights.
If you look out across the water in the main area,
you see the coastline literally dotted by these different buoys.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's very common for one boat to run over another boats line and basically cut
the trap from the buoy.
That's why have two buoys to,
uh,
to protect against the loss,
basically reduces the risk in half.
But,
uh,
what happened in,
and,
uh,
the,
the instance that I'm going to tell you about when I was on the island was that,
uh,
there was,
a newcomer,
a young guy,
about 18 years old who wanted to set traps in this area that had been formerly
allocated to different members of the community.
He wasn't from that town.
He was thought of as an outsider.
Uh,
they saw the new colored,
uh,
buoys,
and they decided that they would teach them a lesson so that they,
uh,
first thing that they did was they,
they cut the line to one of the buoys and they cut it cleanly.
So he would recognize that,
uh,
this was an intentional cut.
If,
uh,
if,
a propeller runs over one of these lines,
uh,
basically phrase the end of it and,
it looks like it's not been cleanly cut.
So he,
he didn't go away.
Uh,
he,
he came back a reset his traps and a,
so that it cut,
uh,
the second line,
of,
uh,
or excuse me,
the second buoy off,
uh,
in addition to the first buoy.
So he lost all of his traps.
Each one of these traps costs about $200.
So if you have five or six of them,
which he had,
it's,
it's not,
uh,
a minor investment.
So he came back the same color of buoys popped up,
uh,
in,
in the area a little bit further out to sea.
So they decided that,
uh,
they're gonna have to take further action.
Uh,
one Lobsterman,
uh,
pulled up and pulled a gun out and shot over his bow,
you know,
a warning shot over the bow,
but literally a shot over the bough a and a that didn't seem to work either.
So,
uh,
one night,
they found where he,
uh,
he kept his boat in the evening and they unscrewed one of his spark plugs from
his engine and put the spark plug inside his gas tank.
Uh,
so he showed up the next morning and turned over his engine and a,
the boat was a blown to smithereens.
Luckily,
he was not seriously injured.
So that a,
that basically,
uh,
taught him the lesson that,
this was,
uh,
not his territory.
And that he should move on.
But what's curious about this is that they have this,
uh,
they had this,
belief in tradition,
uh,
this belief and custom and,
and a belief in that they have the right to fish in that area.
Uh,
and no one else should come in this area.
And the local government doesn't have the capacity to monitor or police this,
nor does the state government or the coast guard or the national marine fishery
service.
So they take the law into their own hands.
So now,
then,
if you ever are around a coastal area,
including the Connecticut coast,
and you see these,
these a lobster buoys out there,
you'll know that they are,
are,
uh,
territorial boundaries that,
have really important economic and legal significance.
Uh,
think,
uh,
think about,
the case of national forest.
Every time I fly to California and I looked down at the rocky mountains,
say I shake my head,
I'm thinking that most of the lands that I'm looking at that look like they're a
denuded of forest,
uh,
our,
our national public,
uh,
domain.
And they've been a basically denuded and,
and the soils of have washed the steeper,
uh,
parts such as this example on the Tsongas national forest in Alaska.
And,
and,
uh,
they have no capacity to regenerate.
And this is because the forest service gave out leases to timber companies to
clear cut on lands that really did not have the capacity to,
to uh,
uh,
sustain that form of,
of timber harvesting.
Clear cutting may be okay if a lans are,
are,
are flatter and,
and you would not have this,
uh,
likelihood of a loss of soil and organic matter that literally prevents,
any form of sustainable timber harvesting so that,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of acres in these a steeper areas,
it at higher elevations,
uh,
now are incapable of supporting timber because of,
of the pressure that's been put on the forest service to give out these property
rights in a sense,
uh,
these,
these timber harvesting rights.
I like to,
uh,
switch gears for a moment and I'm going to begin talking about a number of
cases,
uh,
that,
involve how we manage,
uh,
coastal development and coastal resources.
And I'd like you to think for a moment about the California coastline.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is being managed under the California Coastal Act of 1976 that created the
California coastal commission.
Uh,
and what's unusual about this and,
and,
uh,
important is that they basically took the idea that's embedded in the Adirondack
park agency act.
Uh,
the idea of zoning,
uh,
restricting density of trying to a cluster development in areas that had
existing services and,
and,
uh,
then take areas that were undeveloped and,
apply rules that demanded very large acreages before new development could
occur.
So,
uh,
this,
area,
uh,
lies within,
you know,
roughly about a quarter to a half mile of the California coast and the demands
that the state get involved in permitting,
just the way that the state gets involved in,
in permitting new development up in the Adirondacks so that,
uh,
the California is unusual and it's history of,
of,
uh,
public ownership of,
of the,
uh,
much of the coastline either as state parks or,
or a county parks or in some instances such as the point Reyes national
seashore,
uh,
that,
was carved out from lands.
And I'll speak about in just a moment so that,
uh,
you know,
think about the diverse set of,
of,
of tools.
What strategies could you use to manage coastal development?
Well,
the,
the government might,
uh,
just go in and buy up the land,
exercise their right of eminent domain,
take it out of the public sector,
or can you take it out of the private sector,
excuse me,
uh,
bringing it into the public domain,
which they did,
uh,
at the point Reyes national seashore.
They also did this at the Cape Cod national seashore,
fire island,
national seashore,
a acid Teague island in Maryland,
uh,
and also padre island in Texas.
So this idea of going in and buying up private land in the coastal zone,
uh,
has,
should have a strong interest to a,
to us here in new haven,
uh,
given our proximity to long island sound.
But if you,
if you put this idea of protecting resources in the coastal zone,
in the context of what we now know about climate change and the probability of
sea level rise and the increased frequency of storms,
uh,
that are severe and increased severity of storms,
then,
uh,
you should begin to think about,
the,
the degree of liability that we face collectively as a,
as a nation,
uh,
about the intensity of development that we've allowed in the coastal zone.
So these coastal zone management,
uh,
strategies a bear a lot of attention,
they're,
they're worth thinking about what works,
uh,
in protecting a critical resources,
what doesn't and why and,
and how property rights might be allocated in different ways.
And remember the idea that,
uh,
you know,
rights,
uh,
are not a unitary,
they are a bundle.
They can be allocated in a variety of different ways so that the point raised
national seashore that lies right next to the San Andreas fault is a wonderful
area and,
uh,
to,
to go out and camp on hike and bike on.
Uh,
but it also is a really interesting example of this idea of buying up up part of
the bundle of rights.
So the park service went into this area,
uh,
that was owned by farmers that had fairly large tracks of land,
some,
uh,
hundreds or thousands of acres in size,
but because of its proximity to San Francisco,
property values were increasing quite rapidly during the 1960s in 1970s.
And there were a variety of different condominium development plans that the
parks service began worrying about.
And this,
uh,
this increase in development pressure coincided with the park services,
intent to create more recreational opportunities,
uh,
in coastal areas.
Why would they do that?
Well,
in part because,
uh,
there were not many national parks in coastal areas.
Uh,
but,
but also in part because the US population is concentrated more heavily in
coastal areas than it is in the interior part of the country.
Uh,
and they could expand their political,
uh,
and thereby economic base of support if they located them in,
in areas such as Massachusetts or a Texas or a or California.
So they would,
uh,
they would enjoy a larger budget.
Uh,
they would,
uh,
have a,
a,
a more diverse set of supporters in Congress.
So in this case,
they bought up the development rights,
uh,
to these farms.
Some 20 different farmers,
uh,
agreed to sell the land.
And when the park service does this,
uh,
they may come in and offer you a,
x amount of dollars for your development rights,
uh,
or they may tell you that,
if you don't agree to this deal,
then we're going to exercise eminent domain,
uh,
in full,
and we're going to take over your lands.
So in this case,
all the farmers eventually a agreed to sell the development rights.
And in,
in part the,
uh,
the idea was to protect the open space agricultural character of the area,
which is really quite unique.
Uh,
and you,
you,
you see this,
uh,
and he's ruling pastoral landscapes,
that if it were in the form of a,
uh,
traditional national park,
where timber would not be allowed to be harvested.
No,
no timber leasing,
no,
no.
Uh,
a mineral extraction and national parks,
uh,
no,
leasing of grazing rights.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
and no,
no,
uh,
no farming.
So that,
uh,
these,
restrictions inside a national park made this a split of the bundle of rights.
Uh,
kind of an interesting strategy to maintain the,
uh,
the pastoral character of the area.
Uh,
I'd also like to you to think about a different kind of problem that we face
with respect to,
to mining.
And the mining law of 1872 was quite,
uh,
quite curious and important and environmental history.
Uh,
and it basically states that all valuable minerals in an on lands belonging to
the u s are free and open to exploration and purchased by US citizens.
So that,
uh,
you know,
you could go out and try to stake a claim to a,
to mind on,
on public lands,
you know,
provided that they were not done national park lands or designated Federal
Wilderness Lands and,
uh,
you know,
try to,
to,
to make your fortune.
Uh,
this was amended by the mining and Minerals Policy Act of 1970.
And I'm not going to go through all of this,
uh,
but,
the,
the intent and the purpose was really to promote economic development on the
public lands.
So,
you know,
if you think about the public domain,
many of you think of public lands as being areas,
uh,
that,
the government is protecting and managing for future generations.
Well,
uh,
you know,
most of the public lands,
uh,
are thought of as economic development opportunities,
by,
uh,
those that are responsible for their,
their management,
uh,
whether or not it's mining,
whether or not its timber resources or grazing rights,
uh,
or,
or water resources.
Uh,
the public lands have long been thought of as is playing a critical role in the
economic development of the nation.
This explains in part why the underlying mineral rights or the oil and gas
rights are separable from the surface rights.
And many people do not understand this.
So here's an example of a,
uh,
a problem that we're facing in the West right now.
Uh,
they're called the coal bed methane gas reserves,
and a,
from a,
this is a hand drawn map in the high country news.
He can see that they're scattered from Arizona and New Mexico all the way up,
uh,
into Montana and North Dakota,
by the way,
a,
a plug for the high country news,
uh,
one of,
yells graduates.
Uh,
uh,
Florence Williams is a reporter for the,
has been a reporter for the high country news,
a Yale graduate back in I think the,
uh,
early 1990s.
But,
uh,
you know,
I commend that journal to you if you're interested in,
in western environmental politics in this case.
Uh,
what has happened is that those that own surface rights are often not aware
that,
uh,
the,
federal government,
he's often sold off the underlying oil and gas rights so that farmers are waking
up in the morning,
uh,
to,
notices that,
that,
uh,
their lands are going to be invaded by a bulldozers and roads are going to be
constructed to get,
uh,
mining equipment in,
that looked like this kind of a drilling rig.
Uh,
the technology is quite,
uh,
quite simple actually.
Uh,
there are a variety of different approaches to this,
uh,
but,
but basically,
uh,
the,
the predominant method now used is that,
uh,
forget about the direction of these arrows from the moment.
Uh,
if you want to extract the,
the,
uh,
the methane gas out of a,
a coal bed,
uh,
and vet gas sits in the fishers,
it's often kept there by the,
uh,
water that's also,
in those interests,
disease within the coal bed.
So one way of getting and releasing the methane gas is to pump the water out of
the area.
And the,
uh,
the analogy that's commonly used is that it's like the opening a soda can and
you hear that,
that pop,
uh,
so you release the pressure and the gas comes up,
and his,
uh,
pumped into a storage area.
Well,
what happens when you,
uh,
you pump a whole lot of water out of an area such as this.
And to give you an example of the scale of,
uh,
this,
this extraction operation in the West right now,
uh,
as of about five years ago,
there were nearly 10,000 of these extraction wells that were being,
uh,
actively,
used in a Wyoming,
a alone in the powder river basin,
especially up near Sheridan.
And Ashley Roberts who graduated in the environmental studies major a few years
ago,
wrote her senior essay on this problem in,
in a,
in Sheridan,
Wyoming,
and conducted her own research that demonstrated that a,
the,
this groundwater extraction,
uh,
is occurring at such an enormous rate,
that it,
uh,
it,
it's causing a change in the chemical composition and the biological diversity,
uh,
of this region.
So,
uh,
the,
there are trillions of cubic feet of natural gas beneath the surface here.
So the scale of this operation is,
is really quite remarkable.
And other firms,
uh,
looking at this diagram are now paying attention to the,
the arrows,
uh,
where the,
the,
the gas is being extracted this way.
Uh,
the gas is being extracted a in this method by pumping CO2 down into the
underlying coal bed.
So this is thought of as a,
a,
a win win situation from a miner's perspective in that a CO2 is being injected
and a sequestered,
uh,
under this,
under this hypothesis,
uh,
while the natural gas is being extracted.
Here's an example of one of the unintended consequences from a,
a,
a rancher in southwestern Colorado and,
uh,
Laplata county.
Well,
in the late 1980s,
the kid started lighting the lemonade on fire.
So I knew something was going on.
Why would a,
why would the lemonade catch fire?
Well,
that would catch fire because the methane wasn't a completely extracted a,
it would seep into the groundwater resources,
uh,
so that,
the lemonade had methane that was flammable.
Another example,
you may have read or seen the horse whisperers,
uh,
a film or book a,
so this is a story that,
uh,
has to do with a horse whisperers complaint about cold bath bed,
methane extraction on his property.
He,
the,
the real,
uh,
horse whisperer.
The trainer,
uh,
woke up one morning,
to bulldozers,
carving a road across his property and he was outraged and he was one of the,
uh,
the ranchers that w was not aware that the underlying mineral rights were
separable from the surface rights and that,
uh,
he,
he thought that he got his gun out and,
uh,
thought that,
you know,
he could drive these people off the land and checking with authorities.
He found that they actually had a purchase the lease a to,
to extract the minerals from beneath the land.
So that a,
he was basically left with trying to figure out how he could minimize the damage
so that,
uh,
he did not have a right to stop them.
Uh,
they,
they built the roads.
They built the,
uh,
the wells,
they extracted the gas,
the water that was pumped up a change,
the chemical composition of,
of water.
And in,
uh,
on,
on his,
uh,
lands and in is a streams and a drainage areas.
Uh,
and also the ditching,
uh,
and,
the,
the diking that was a necessary to control the water,
uh,
made it dangerous for him to run his cattle.
So a lot of the farmers are experiencing a more dangerous situation,
uh,
to,
to pursue their own livelihood.
So here's another example of,
of a,
you know,
what it looks like from,
from the air.
Now these patches,
this patchwork quilt of,
of a extraction sites,
uh,
that so now tens of thousands of these things,
had been constructed across the western United States.
So one way to think about this is to think about the law of Nuisance,
uh,
an act,
a object or practice that interferes with another's rights or interests by being
offensive,
annoying,
dangerous,
obstructive,
or unhealthful.
Uh,
there's a distinction between what's thought of as a public nuisance and a
private nuisance.
So a public nuisance,
uh,
interferes with the collective interest and criminal prosecution.
Uh,
maybe the remedy,
but a private news nuisance,
uh,
maybe thought of as a tort or a civil wrong,
at any activity that interferes with the enjoyment and use of one's property.
I e the horse whisperer is property,
uh,
and it may be the basis for civil litigation.
So the horse whisperer does have,
as it would these other ranchers,
uh,
the,
the opportunity to,
uh,
to take the,
drilling company,
the gas company,
the mining company to court.
Uh,
but,
but you know,
that,
uh,
that form of litigation often spans long periods of time so that to avoid
litigation,
uh,
if you were the minor or the,
the,
the gas extractor,
what would you do?
You would try to enter into some sort of a,
uh,
a legal agreement with each of the,
the farmers,
uh,
that,
you would pay them x amount of money if they would agree not to litigate.
So there's a lot of,
of,
uh,
legal agreements that underlie these,
these wells.
Uh,
and another nuisance case from the 1880s that has a bearing on this.
If land use is considered to be a nuisance,
it may be regulated without compensation.
Well,
so that a,
the damages in this case might be regulated by a local government agency.
So local governments traditionally have the role of a adopting zoning and
subdivision regulations in a way that would control these kinds of nuisance.
Uh,
so in,
in one case,
a,
this nuisance was defined,
uh,
by Mugler versus Kansas.
A supreme court decision back in 1887,
uh,
where the sale of alcoholic beverages was,
was believed to be a public nuisance and prevented by regulation.
Uh,
and in this case,
compensation was not required.
So not all rights to use the land were removed as the land could still be used
for other purposes.
So the idea that a government could regulate land and not be required to
compensate a,
that the land owner,
in this case,
the owner of the,
the store that sold alcoholic beverages,
uh,
that,
that's an interesting idea.
Uh,
but the,
the condition here is that not all of the rights were removed.
And that he had other opportunities to make economic use of that land.
So keep that in mind as you think about a takings law.
Another famous case in takings law history is Euclid versus Ambler.
Uh,
the,
the origin,
uh,
this is a supreme court decision,
from 1926,
uh,
where a land use ordinance that segregated residential and commercial districts
was challenged.
Uh,
its constitutionality was challenged,
uh,
and uh,
it was believed by private interests that the restrictions on new development,
uh,
in each zone,
was,
uh,
taking because it removed the value of that property.
So if an individual was in a residential zone and they wanted to build a store
shopping center or a casino,
they would not be allowed to do so.
So that the authority of the state or local governments acting on behalf of
states to restrict land use,
to segregate land,
use,
uh,
to,
to control density.
Uh,
this has been substantiated as early as 1926.
So the Supreme Court concluded at state police power may be used to classify and
regulate land use to prevent nuisances.
Another case,
it's interesting,
uh,
and one that I'm sure all of you have been to is,
the case of,
uh,
Penn central transportation company versus the city of New York decided in 1978.
So the question here surrounded grand central station.
Now Grand Central Station,
uh,
at that time was managed by the Penn Central Transportation Company and the city
of New York decided that they wanted to designate,
uh,
grand central station as an historic landmark and thereby prohibit development
above the terminal a.
Now,
would this be constituted with this constituted taking a property without
compensation?
So here's another kind of,
right.
Uh,
so that uh,
right,
uh,
to subsurface resources such as oil and gas needs to be considered.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the right,
associated with building on the surface needs to be considered.
But,
uh,
this is an argument about air rights.
So if you own the surface rights,
do you also own the air rights or could the government come in and restrict your
ability to,
uh,
build to an infinite height?
Well,
zoning ordinance is commonly have building height restrictions.
And in this case it was a bit unusual because the district that,
uh,
grand central station is in,
I mean,
you walk out and you see the Yale Club and the Yale Club has just about as high
as a grand central station.
Uh,
but,
uh,
then look around you and you see office buildings that are towering,
you know,
dozens and dozens of stories in height.
And in this case,
the Supreme Court affirmed that the restrictions imposed by the New York City's
landmark preservation law,
uh,
on Penn central's right to construct an office building above,
the terminal do not constitute a taking of private property.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it upheld the legitimacy of the designation of the site as an historic landmark,
and the authority of New York to,
uh,
to regulate,
air rights.
So one cannot presume that they have a kind of infinite freedom,
uh,
to build,
to a greater height.
I to bring another Supreme Court case to your attention that's curious.
Uh,
this is Hawaii housing authority versus Midkiff decided in 1984,
uh,
now Hawaii is really a,
an unusual state.
And,
uh,
back in,
prior to this time,
96% of the state was owned by 72 land owners or the state or the federal
government.
It's just think about that for a moment.
So 96% of the state was honed by just a handful of land owners.
Uh,
so that 1967,
the Hawaii legislature approved the use of eminent domain to condemn residential
lots and sell land to existing tenants.
Now,
if they're only seven 72 landowners in Hawaii,
and I don't know what the population of why I was at that time,
but let's just say for sake of argument,
that it was a,
uh,
a million people.
Uh,
basically that meant that,
uh,
most of those people,
the overwhelming majority of them will be forced into a tenancy relationship
with the land owner so that they would have to enter into a lease agreement.
But the legislature's had,
well,
you know,
we basically want to break up this oligopoly,
even if the land owners object,
and we should have the right to do that.
So they literally went in and,
uh,
appropriated the land.
Uh,
but they compensated the land owners so that these 90,
these 72,
uh,
land owners did receive compensation and then they sold the land back to the
existing tenants.
So this is really a,
a fairly dramatic act on the part of any state government.
And it also raised questions about the use of eminent domain.
And the Supreme Court in this case found that,
uh,
that this was a legitimate use of,
the,
the constitutional right,
that,
uh,
the,
the government has to exercise eminent domain and that it's not a taking a,
that the single most important criterion to justify the use of eminent domain.
It's the nature of the public use a on a public use is created even when
immediately turned over to private hands.
And in this case,
uh,
the public use or the key public interest was defined by the breakup of the land
oligopoly.
Uh,
another,
uh,
take on what public uses was decided to just several years ago,
right here in Connecticut,
about 40 miles away in new London in a case known as key low versus the city of
New London.
Uh,
where the supreme court found that the use of eminent domain in that case,
uh,
by the,
the city of New London,
uh,
because it wanted to,
to,
uh,
encourage redevelopment of an area that was in private ownership.
It decided that it would use eminent domain,
uh,
and then it would sell the land back to a private developer.
So that,
uh,
as in the Hawaii case,
either the,
the,
uh,
the large land holding was broken up and then,
redistributed to,
to willing buyers.
Uh,
in this case the developer was already known to the city of New London,
uh,
so that the private reits were transferred first to the city,
but then back to the private development organization.
And the court found that a,
if an economic project creates new jobs,
increases taxes or other city revenues and revitalizes the depressed urban area,
then that qualifies as a public use and it's a little bit legitimate exercise of
eminent domain and does not require compensation.
Uh,
now this was decried by,
uh,
by many who argued that,
you know,
the Supreme Court really had a lost its bearing.
Uh,
and this cartoon gives you a sense of that.
And a,
this cartoon is a,
the Supreme Court sitting on its front steps with a wrecking ball sitting in
front of it.
Uh,
with a caption thanks to your ruling on eminent domain.
We can finally level this building to make way for a Chucky cheese
so that the decision about when a taking his occurred is often dependent upon
when a regulatory action renders property to be valueless.
So,
uh,
take you back to the Adirondacks for a moment and have you think about,
the way that the,
the Adirondack park was regulated.
So,
uh,
you know,
rewind back to 1972 before the park agency existed and just assume that you had
a hundred acres of land and you had a,
had a intended that you are going to sell off one acre per year and that was
really going to also provide retirement for you and your family.
Uh,
1973,
the state legislature passes a law and lo and behold,
you are in the green area and that means that you will,
you require 42.3 acres for a new building.
Uh,
now shouldn't that constitute a taking?
So that a year expectation that you could sell off a hundred lots,
uh,
under the old zoning ordinance,
was being dashed and,
and,
uh,
now you could only sell off to lots,
and uh,
uh,
what does,
shouldn't the government had the obligation to compensate you for that loss and
in right,
uh,
in that loss in value?
Well,
the supreme court has argued across a wide diversity of cases that,
that uh,
uh,
if you are left with a property right,
that has some lingering,
a remnant value than a taking has not occurred.
Uh,
this was established back in 1922 in a case that's a quite interesting
Pennsylvania coal company versus Mahoen a statue that prohibited the mining of
coal underground in a manner that causes substance of homes on the surface.
I went too far and did constitute a taking.
So imagine if a coal company started digging under your family home.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the extent of the ditch digging or the,
uh,
the instability of the,
the,
uh,
the geology caused your,
your,
your land surface to subside and cave in and,
and,
uh,
harm your property.
Uh,
uh,
does the,
does the government,
uh,
have the,
the,
uh,
the right to prohibit a mining company from,
from digging under underground?
Well,
uh,
in this case,
the,
the court had argued that,
uh,
the,
the Prohibition of mining,
uh,
did constitute a taking why?
Well,
because the underlying mineral rights became worthless.
All the value was taken away from the underlying mineral value.
Oliver Wendell Holmes wrote,
while property may be regulated to a certain extent,
if regulation goes too far,
it will be recognized as a taking.
So the key question and most of these regulatory cases is a,
when is it gone too far?
I'll give you another example from the Adirondacks from a personal experience.
And there was a developer that wanted to build on a,
uh,
river,
area that,
uh,
was designated under the New York state,
wild scenic and recreational rivers act.
And this developer wanted to build a about a hundred new units,
uh,
right along the river.
The park agency came along and decided that,
uh,
it would damage,
the,
uh,
a flood plane.
It would cause physical structures to sit in the flood plain.
The flood plain.
For those of you that don't know the term is an area that's designated by a,
a boundary that sits at the,
uh,
a location and elevation of a probable 100 year flood.
Uh,
so that the,
it's,
it's probable that,
that,
uh,
that intensity of storm will,
will not occur except once every hundred years,
by the way,
new haven and,
uh,
my home experienced almost a a hundred year storm,
just last week.
So all of the,
uh,
the,
low line lands were,
were flooded in the area.
[inaudible] Connecticut River is,
is just cresting now from the storm last week.
Uh,
so that many people aren't aware of this a hundred year flood,
flood plain.
So that in this case,
the decision was made not to allow the development in the flood plane and,
uh,
basically to a permit the land to be used for different kind of a purpose.
In that particular instance,
it was a camp ground that was allowed so that the,
uh,
the property owner went to court and claimed that his property rights in his
value had been taken by the government and that he demanded he demanded
compensation.
Uh,
and in New York State Supreme Court found that,
that,
uh,
no,
it was not taken.
In fact,
he was left with a perfectly viable economic use,
uh,
which would be the continuance of his campground.
Give you a,
another example here,
uh,
from a coastal area in California,
Nolan versus the California coastal commission.
Nolan had a leased property in Ventura,
California.
Uh,
and he,
he,
uh,
at least it with the option to buy,
but it was conditioned on the replacement of a 500 square foot bungalow and it
required a permit from the agency.
I mentioned a few moments ago,
the California Coastal Commission,
uh,
the coastal commission found that the new house would block the ocean view
contributing to the development of a wall of residential structures,
uh,
that would prevent the public psychologically from realizing a stretch of
coastline,
uh,
that exists nearby,
that they have every right to visit.
Uh,
so to give you some sense of,
uh,
this case,
here's an aerial shot looking down at,
uh,
at the Nolan Bungalow here,
and you can see that all these,
uh,
structures are,
are sitting,
they're actually sitting at the base of a cliff,
uh,
north of Los Angeles.
And like many of the California coast area that is privately owned,
uh,
you find these houses separated only by several feet,
these bungalows.
So what would be the effect of,
uh,
of building higher a while the California coastal commission,
I was concerned about the obstruction of the view from the public.
So in effect,
it was a question about psychological or visual access so that it would,
uh,
the court found that the new house would increase private use of the shorefront
and would cumulatively burden the public's ability to traverse a,
to traverse to and along the shore front.
So the,
the coastal commission granted a permit requiring public,
a public access easement.
So this is kind of interesting so that the problem that they found was blocked
visual access,
but the remedy that they required was physical access.
Now you may not understand that in California,
physical access to the coastal area is thought of as a,
a very important public.
Right?
Uh,
and so Nolan,
the,
uh,
the person who had bought the,
the,
a option to buy,
uh,
looked at the access condition as a taking,
he didn't want to provide access across his property for the public.
He didn't want to worry about,
uh,
the public traipsing over his land,
or,
uh,
concerns about security.
And if the Supreme Court listen to the case,
and it said that if California wants an easement across Nolan's property,
it must pay for it.
Yeah,
this constituted a taking without compensation.
And this is,
uh,
the definition of what's come to be known as the nexus argument.
So that the,
the,
uh,
projected damage in this case,
the lack of visual access from a higher building was being remedied by a,
an easement,
a demand on the part of the,
of the state to provide public access.
So the court looked at that and said,
you know,
there's no real connection between the remedy and,
uh,
the,
the hypothetical damage.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
in cases where,
where,
uh,
there is a damage that is being claimed by a private land owner,
this would demand that any successful attempt to,
to,
uh,
seek compensation,
look to this,
uh,
the,
the quality and the strength of,
of the nexus argument.
I'm going to leave you with one final case here.
And this is the case of Florida.
And given my earlier comments about climate change and the vulnerability of,
of a coastal environments,
I can think of almost no other state in the union that has more property value
that is liable,
uh,
or excuse me,
that is susceptible to loss.
And then the state of Florida and the state of Florida has a,
a very active beach renourishment program.
So in the face of storms and the hurricane damage,
you know,
one of the responses is,
uh,
to,
I'm going to scoot ahead here.
One of the responses is to a park barges offshore and pump sand from offshore
areas,
uh,
onto the beach.
Uh,
for those of you that are interested in geology,
there's a kind of a very interesting science about the grain size.
And,
and they,
they test very carefully the green size of the sands offshore.
Uh,
and they know that some of the larger grains are more stable than the,
than the smaller Greens,
uh,
so that they will be less prone to erosion.
So the teams just think about what you're looking at here.
This is sitting on a barrier island.
It's a strip of land that literally is now no more than a quarter of mile,
uh,
and width.
Uh,
and behind it lies a bay.
this is typical of barrier islands in the United States.
And in this case,
you probably have hundreds of millions of dollars of real estate value value
that is highly vulnerable.
So that a,
you know,
in the face of sea level rise,
we're going to be basically looking at coastal areas as those in,
in the Netherlands have.
Uh,
in other words,
thinking about how to,
uh,
to keep the coast a safe,
how to push back the water,
how to reflect the,
the wave energy by building dikes or sea walls,
or in this case beach nourishment.
There's another example of buildings,
uh,
almost,
almost sitting in the water,
uh,
and the erosion that is occurring following storms.
So,
and here's another example of what the state of,
of,
of a Florida is doing to,
to build up that,
uh,
that beach front.
So,
uh,
just,
a quick version here,
uh,
in,
Walton County,
uh,
the Florida wanted to renourish.
Uh,
the,
the shorefront was sand,
uh,
under the provisions of the Florida is beach and shore preservation act that was
recently adopted.
It fixed boundary between the publicly owned land and privately,
privately owned land.
So that,
you know,
imagine that this is your house and imagine that you have a thin strip of sand
between your house and in the ocean,
which is a this open area in front of the stage here.
And then imagine that,
uh,
the state lost and you think of yourself as being a,
shorefront owner and a,
that a republic has no right of access across your area because the mean high
water mark,
uh,
sits down a ways from where you are now.
Supposing that the state comes through and decides they want to nourish the
beach,
we're going to build up that area so that the state literally set a boundary
between the private land in the public land and the sh the property owners of
private property owners argue that that was a taking that was a taking of their
property,
right.
Uh,
to,
uh,
own shorefront.
Uh,
because now there was private land up to the edge of the stage.
and then beyond that where the,
the,
uh,
stand had been deposited,
that was a strip of public land that was open for public access so that these
land owners wanted to a exclusive right to control that area.
Well,
the,
uh,
they alleged that the Florida Supreme Court violated the due process and takings
causes,
uh,
by suddenly and unpredictably changing state substantive law to deprive these
owners of their private property without compensation.
And the Florida Supreme Court rule that beach front property owners had no right
to their property to continue contact with water nor any vested right a future
beach accretion.
So the court,
uh,
argued that basically they didn't know what was going to happen in that area
that was,
uh,
at or that is now open water,
that,
uh,
the private landowner doesn't have any right of expectation that,
that the,
that,
uh,
their land would just simply extend all the way down to the mean high water
mark.
You have to state kept dumping sand in front of it so that this has become a
very popular case that's pending before the supreme court now.
And it may be decided in the next week or so.
Uh,
so it stopped the beach nourishment a versus the county and a coalition of 26
states have,
uh,
supported,
Amoco Amoco briefs,
uh,
including the Obama administration.
So that,
uh,
during the argument in front of the Supreme Court,
it was interesting because the solicitor general that represents the United
States government in the Supreme Court,
uh,
made a case in favor of the states' rights to a,
to a renourish.
The lands,
uh,
every state in the,
in the country that has coastal property,
uh,
has an interest in this because they do not want to have to compensate private
owners,
uh,
for any activity that they take to try to,
to prevent additional property damage.
Uh,
I'm going to zoom ahead here and then we'll conclude and just a minute.
But remember also that pesticide regulation raises the questions of property
rights and takings because the government's required in the case where we're,
the government bans a chemical that is already licensed,
uh,
it's required to purchase existing stocks of newly band products,
so that even though they find that a chemical is,
is more dangerous than they thought,
and they had previously licensed it,
if they've got new evidence of risk and they take away the right to market that
product,
the chemical companies can successfully argue and have argued that that
constitutes or taking a takings that a is compensable.
So there are 23,000 of these registrations out there.
Uh,
I'm going to conclude with a,
uh,
one,
one final thought.
Uh,
and that is that,
that,
uh,
among all these strategies,
that might be applied to protect a public resources and,
and,
uh,
also,
to protect,
uh,
private,
PR protect against private damage,
uh,
to the environment.
Uh,
the,
the use of regulation is an extremely important,
uh,
opportunity for state and local governments so that,
if you apply a strict standard,
uh,
against takings,
in other words,
if you,
if you demand that,
uh,
taking of all property value be required prior to the,
prior to the grant of compensation that offers the greatest opportunity for
governments to be effective in pursuing an environmental agenda's.
So we'll come back and talk a bit more,
uh,
at the end of the week about,
several alternative strategies,
particularly marketing of ecosystem service payments.
Thank you.